How hard is it to receive
A pro table tennis serve?
We challenged 20 strangers
And if they received our serve
they got 100 dollars
Make sure you watch untill the end
to see how many could do it
Our first challenger
Three chances
And all you got to do is get one serve back
Yeah he looks like he can play
I'm ready!
Thanks man!
Good try.
- Thank you
First challenger,
no serves back
Okay, you ready for this?
Yeah, no!
Wait, wait...
Ok go!
I got it!
One on the table 100 dollars
Otto you know what serve you going to do?
I think i have a good serve
He curved it!!
- Actually close!
Dang it!
Thank you
It was on the table!
You owe me a hundred dollars!
I got it back
Oh, close!
Okay, one more
Hundred bucks for getting it back on the table?
So, the first serve
Oh, good!
That was so close!
You gotta give your number one serve
- yeah!
That's it!
100 dollars
He get's it!
Good job
Have a bottle of wine on me tonight!
You got to get your prize
Alright, here you go
If you prefer
Our own table tennis racket
I'm out for a run,
Do you think i can run with this?
Yeah, just stick it up the pants!
Wanna give it a go?
We've got our next contender
Yeah
My eyes
Are 52 years old
It's coming over there
That's nice of you
Okay I hit it
Is it still coming on this side?
Maybe
- Oh shoot
I finger clipped it
Alright, thank you
that was fun
- thanks!
You did well
We have to get some more
Challengers
We're gonna pull out the sign
Let's go put it on the road
So people find it
Anybody who's gonna go through this
Will be coming over
I'd accept the challenge
Do you wanna come and challenge us?
I'll do it!
You get one of them on the table
You get 100 dollars
*excitement sounds*
That was the first one
That's two!
Oh my god, he's putting a spin on it!
I'm gonna serve it in the middle
Don't tell me anything!
And that was a crazy receive
Thank you
That was so good
- I'm so happy i did this!
And it was a good receive
I didn't know what i did
There you go!
Thank you
Receive one serve get 100 dollars
I want you to
Respond to my serve first
How do you say thank you in Finnish?
Kiitos!
Mel TV live is in the house
I'm a local celebrity here
And i'm here to make my hundred dollars
You got my money?
I don't want this to be in krona
or whatever
Or Yen or whatever they do in Finland
Okay, I want real money
US dollars baby
Benjamins, right
We're going to do this, hundred dollars
If i do this repetedly
Is it one hundred, one hundred....
Can it add up?
It would probably be easier if I would be on the other side
You want to come on this side?
You want home field advantage
I'll give it to you!
These guys are good
Is it legal?
Close, close
That was so close!
That was a really good try
Thanks
- Thank you
You guys are good
Trying to get my kids up here
Keep bringing relatives up here
Until I get 100 dollars out of you guys
I'm so excited
I've been wanting to play with you guys for so long
I found out you guys live in Finland
And thought this is never going to happen
Here is your racket
Oh...
No I'm gonna do it okay
I just wanna see if I can like...
Just look at the guy!
Well you hit it
Two more tries left
But now you've got the real racket
It's gonna come in a little hot
Just tap it over
Good coaching!
First one
My god!
But you hit it!
And it was pretty close
Thanks
- that was fun
I've got Colton and Liam here
These are two superstar athletes
From the Pacific Palacades neighbourhood
There you go
Oh, nice
Here's your racket
Good, good!
"Watch the ball"
You were in the right place
Good tries!
That was so close
Okay your turn
You hit it
That's one hundred dollars!
My man!
- Let's GO!
I got a hundred bucks!
Congratulations
Thanks
Don't give it to your dad
I take fifty percent!
It was so sunny and now it's freezing cold here
It's like Finland
Yeah I think we'll have to wrap thing up now
Alright until next time!